ben pensarci bene a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
dj ed oggi siamo tornati su al plus per
chi non l'avesse vista ragazzi consiglio
rivedersi prima la serie a è quella
originale tanto trovate annotazioni qua
sopra loro non vedevo l'ora che uscisse
al plus twist blogger che sarebbe il dlc
che sarebbe il seguito credo sia al
seguito credo concas e stiamo nel menù
non lo scopriremo mai quindi direi
ricominciare lega
andiamo allora difficoltà normale
difficili incubo folle io mi butto sul
incubo perchè tanto lo so che non dormo
uguale quindi va bene lo stesso e poi
non ho capito i ragazzi sarà ambientato
dopo primipare prima se non se non erro
pe non mi ricordo chiesto tizio rega ho
bisogno di un paio di occhiali perché
non vedo un cazzo a prescindere che
cos'è a hubble già ragazzi si rimorchia
così da adesso in avanti perché
ma tu sei più sexy ragazzi c'è gente
veramente sexy che mi sta tocca mettila
ritoccarmi il pene ragazzini palpano
ciao hai dei bellissimi occhi
apri gli occhi a testa di merda qual è
il problema qualcuno ti ha colpito
ecco lascia che ti aiuti non mi capitino
una testata che ragazzi un pervertito di
merda reja 9 andrew hore sta ricevendo
che 16 sembrano problemi seri al motore
dicono che aveva abbia fatto
un'ascensione laterale billy o cazzo e
non sono felici no cazzo cazzo che cazzo
cazzo cazzo cazzo
vabbè andiamo ragazzi non non ho capito
un cazzo di quello che ha detto perché
c'è la mia le creato infatti una del
karting fax o madonna che schifo se ti
becco tipico una testa due ore prima io
non so che cosa è successo so soltanto
che un tizio mia leccate in faccia e non
è una cosa che non mi conosci devo fare
in fretta forse mi controllano lavorato
da settimane come consulente informatico
nella clinica psichiatrica murcof di
mons beh sì che sarebbe a quella dove
c'erano tutti pazzi per infrangere
tonnellate di cosa lì è va beh non leggo
più una stecca ovviamente uno si mette a
scrivere i lunghi cosa fa
in tensione ragazzino io non so perché è
una persona dovrebbe scrivere in un
posto del genere io già mi caga ray ad
hoc già visto anche arrivando addosso in
camera mia figuratevi dentro succedono
cose orribili non riesco a capire anzi
non riesco a credere nemmeno a metà di
quello che ho visto i dottori parlano di
una terapia dei sogni è andata troppo
oltre i velando qualcosa che li aspetta
solo montagna gente soffre quelli da
molto affanno i soldi devono saperlo
tutti ragazzi dal pulsante sinistro del
mouse inviare un'e mail
ho inviato la mail kitchen è successo
cosa diamo con software lo sto facendo
niente dico niente come stavo
controllando le notifiche di facebook
non c'è problema stai tranquillo ci
siamo mi posso muovere impossibile sei
qui ma che bello che sei perché ti hanno
fatto mi chiama real cerca persone già
tre volte c'è un'emergenza al motore a
sentirmi nuovo obiettivo era lui
soddisfare il motore morpho james cole
zio tu non sai ke kazzo passato prima
mia mi hanno leccato in faccia tu non
hai idea di quello che passa ma non
importa dove cazzo siamo asi quest'anno
raga questo è il posto che c'era nel
finale di auto a scuola prima serie
solo che parimenti adesso adesso ci sono
persone dove prima non c'erano si vede
che questo è prima che succedesse tutto
quel casino dalla padiglioni andare
avanti perché dove cazzo stanarlo non lo
so neanch'io ma non importa mondo tu sei
veramente in figure cristo non sbrigati
stanno aspettato che ho capito ma non
c'è pagina il culo c'è un attimo madonna
la gente qua c'è uno stile che non avete
idea
sei arrivato proprio al limite ho capito
è arrivata lì mi siedo è mi siedo bene
ne so di preciso non si capisce un cazzo
ok ragazzi c'è un tizio nudo c'è un
tizio modo che si sta portando via la
gente allora york l'importante che inizi
qualche film così mi distraggo lo sapevo
che stava per succedere questi schifosi
comunque è una cosa star cosa fa
ok calcio al musical calmo ai dei vecchi
appelli alla cristiano ronaldo ma non
importa è una cosa sta succedendo
aiutami non lasciare che mi facciano
questo amico mio mi sono seduto dio non
è colpa mia ma va tutto bene adesso
ehi tu sei quello che ma le carte in
faccia brutto stronzo ragazzi non torna
al tuo ufficio va bene io sì ho capito
però tu mai legate in faccia lui il
nostro anche una testata pd ora non ha
idea di dove mio ufficio poi non mi
ricordi qua io io vado d qual giorno
davvero dover all'inizio in poche parole
sembra che non ci sia qualcuno non c'è
nessun perfetto io non ho ancora capito
perché qualcuno sta facendo la spia
cazzo e vabbè ma affanculo però metti le
mani dove posso vedersi va beh ma sede
strano insieme testa di minchia di
taglio le braccia pura tecnica ragazzi
signor ma in un park contratto di
collaborazione esterna
sperimentiamo hanno beccato perché ho
mandato quella melli prima va cuore sì
però siete stranzi fa il mio computer
forse potrebbe somministrare al signor
park no no no perché bastardi ragazzi le
buone maniere l'anno la chan e vabbè dai
tenuta a trevi già che ci siete
whistleblower ragazzi mi hanno leccato
la faccia mi hanno spiattellato 1 nudo
sul vetro mi hanno picchiato è successo
di tutto in cinque minuti non è
possibile
vabbè ma siamo rimasti dove lo prima e
dove mi avevano legato alla faccia
perfetto successo poi ho capito che è
successo sì solo libero può saltar mi si
può posso alzarmi bene e non lo senti
vero
c'è un tizio frutto dietro perfetto mi
sa che se n'è accorto ok
bene bene non ho capito che cazzo
successo ma non importa
però a me hanno sempre legato alla
faccia quindi è peggio per me posso
prendere che grazie a dio
ragazzi ho trovato una videocamera che
almeno con questa fosse finalmente non
mi ricordo come ci si muove ragazzi con
la videocamera però non importa c'è un
tizio brutto che ha ucciso gli altri mi
sa i fatti mi sa che c'è un po di sangue
salve senta io sono fessi di essere al
sicuro gli ultimi doppiare lino cazzo ti
apre in due notti a pro in tua sorella
aprendo ti faccio godere aspetto che
cazzo dici ragazzi qua sono tutti i
pervertiti ma è possibile cioè ma sono
finito in un manicomio di maniaci
ragazzi fate qualcosa vi prego no no no
amico mio non ti grattare il pene si sta
vicina al prefetto ha cambiato ha
cambiato direzione non ho mai capito chi
è conditio ma
io io vado avanti nel dubbio non so
neanche che cazzo è successo di preciso
tienilo fermo oddio che cazzo stampa c'è
ragazzi
ok no no io ho risparmiato un po di
scene ragazzi non importa facciamo finta
di non vedere comunque la cosa bella
visto gioca solo nudo c'è uno ho visto
un tizio modo che correva non è non lo
sono sognato
serve un cazzo oggi ai ragazzi con
tiziano quel tizio non è cosa buona mi
sa merda come poi vado di qui la prima
porta bastardo dov'è dov'è che non lo
dove ragazzi e sparito è sparito il
tizio di prima che mi congo ho visto un
tizio nudo io prima e non è che ma state
cucinando qualcosa col ketchup
appello del giro fatemi capire allora io
vado di qua perché per tizio mi stanno
guardando malissimo
dato che c'è il tizio nudo che corre ma
ripensandoci torno indietro e allora
fatemi capire che cosa cazzo devo fare
che non ho capito ma si può entrare di
quattro spenta ma io non entrerei qua
dentro a babel
forse sono costretto ti si sono entrato
il nostro tom sbircio ne viene a
partecipare alla nostra sessione di
terapia è allora guarda io l'affettato
non lo gradisce si ringrazia ho detto
che non lo gradisco preferisco la pasta
finita la masca ma un po nel nostro
amico qui ma non voglio scavare nel
dottore senti ma fate una terapia
facciale pure tu se ti trattieni per
troppo tempo potessi fare qualcosa di
cui ti penti non sei uno di quelli
troppo buono partiti come noi
pensi di essere differente speciale
ma io uscirei volentieri esco con
piacere fuori siete molto genti a una
cosa prima però prima di uscire due
amici che stavo dei ragazzi possiamo
uscire definitivamente chiudo anche la
porta sono un gentleman
ok non me l'aspettavo dove castellanza
[ __ ] c'è chi come ti permetti stronzo
ragazzi sono santa binari fan culo
pezzenti di merda ex pazzo successo di
un chiodi è perfetto dove dove posso
andare prima che si apra la porta dove
posso andare di qua ragazzi che mi si s
di qui a un ok che culo
l'ho trovata purtroppo fan curve
rispetto ragazza altro che solid snake
qua siamo in al plaza ancora peggio mi
sono preso il cazzo di bard per sim ed e
andiamo alla reception
non sappiamo neanche se la radio
funziona ragazzi quelli sono sani di
mente quindi sono cattivi
raggiungi la radio nella prigione allora
addio raggiungere la radio per chiamare
a sé per chiamare aiuto perfetto che
sono nella merda in poche parole lui
prende la responsabilità di ogni cosa
legalmente discutibile essendosi già che
c'è un tizio a terra la cosa promette
malissimo ma non in poi riuscendo se ti
alzi che azzurro che ti di lancio sul
termosifone che c'è qui la fatemi uscire
prima che quel tizio riprendo male
perché non lo so no no ho detto che devi
stare seduto senti e vin diesel
metti tv dove stavi prima perché non mi
piace la cosa che ti sei alzato il
braccio non si è incazzato e questo va
già bene dove deve andare vado riquadro
di qualche effetto ha chiuso ha chiuso
la porta
[Applauso]
cazzo succede ragazzi è di nuovo lo
spettro cazzo che cos'era sto rumore che
non mi è piaciuto per niente
vado di qua prima che succeda qualcosa
di brutto non so dove starà a buongiorno
senta lei bell'uomo aiutami ti prego
sono un dottore devo tornare a casa dai
miei ma [ __ ] non se ne la
sicurezza io ero sono paziente come te
ma vaffan quanti credono mai però ti
apro lo stesso perché sono buono d'animo
ed enti meriti ti presento il mio amico
amico mio allora questo è evin l'ho
incontrato prima è un tipo molto
socievole molto simpatico lo cioccolato
un paio di volte ragazzi si stanno
divertendo e vetro si divertono io
andrei avanti di preciso grazie prego
non lo so intanto ci sono degli
armadietti così se succede qualcosa
posso nascondermi non so che cazzo
succede ma torno indietro la sicurezza
ok ragazzi non so che a cazzo sta
succedendo di preciso ma cos'è tu cos'è
gli pre cosa stato
no no eh ma allora si bastardo ma
[ __ ]
come ha fatto a trovarmi ma vado
nell'altro vaffan cuore non hanno
sbagliato tasto sbagliato fottutamente
tasto entra qui no e che cazzo ragazzi
non c'è verso
senta io sono qui per caso e io vado di
qui vado di qua o al giorno ragazzi non
so neanche come cazzo fatto scappare ma
molliamo neanche quel tizio mi raggiunga
vedi qua di qua si ok questo stato sono
subito che non so neanche come cazzo
fatto salorino non ne arriva un altro
arriva un'altra cosa
già uno ne basta è fossero di mano più
no l'uscita [ __ ] è ma siete
stronzi forte però dai lo devo andare
ragazzi che ho perso ho perso tutto non
c'è più una porta male iniziata forse di
qua no di qua è chiuso
ecco perfetto devo fare il devo farti
passassi inscritto passare sopra le è
perfetta ma è così perché se noi non
usiamo le porte usiamo tutt'altro
siccome ragazzi non ancora capito dove
sto andando perché l'entrata era
dall'altra parte madonna questa sta
messa peggio di me sta gente non importa
andiamo avanti lo stesso e tu chi cazzo
serie c è quel tizio regalo benissimo
dovete spiegare perché sto andando da
quel piano sta cucinando ma dirlo subito
ma gradisco un piatto anch'io grazie
vediamo se questo sta facendo ragazze
usciamo di qui prima che quello di via
male non più da ragazzi posso guardarlo
davanti e aspetta che lo
ok forse è meglio di no forse è meglio
di no io torni indietro grazie mille non
guardarci lo sa lo amo
[Musica]
ma che bello quando una persona da il
cuore ad un altro ecco perfetto come non
detto
e se proprio mi sa che lui ha preso un
po troppo alla lettera la faccenda del
dammi il tuo cuore ti amerò per sempre
no non mi piace su rumore di che c'è lo
spettro vero dimmi che non c'è lo
spettro perché non c'ho voglia di
correre
non c'è lo spettro perfetto perché ce
l'ho fatta penso se penso sia al sicuro
poi arrampicati che ce l'ha fatta
aprite aprite strada c'è un tizio non
avevo neanche visto bisogna togliere
manette a questa porta dove dovrei
trovare le chiavi fatemi capire a si può
passare qua per te è veramente io dalle
ragazze dall uscita potrebbe uscire così
ragazzi c'è il tizio di prima che era
innamorato quello che mi ha visto
perfetto allora è come l'ho detto come
non detto come non detto
come non detto gustavo ragazzi dico non
c'arriva dicono già arrivati con arriva
su khan hsupa vorrei puntualizzare sul
fatto che c'è un po e cosa in mano che
mi pare vagamente un dildo un po grosso
ma non gli porta peggior di riuscire a
fare un qualcosa di decente sono
inciampato sul letto un genio cit
inciampare sul letto mentre c'è un tizio
con una motosega in mano vediamo di
chiarirci bene le idee semi rincorri
madonna quante legnate
non ho mai visto tu non hai visto tu non
mi hai visto bravo è passato di qui a
julio corro corro mai così a caso eccoti
qui carne ma [ __ ] carne sarà tua
sorella
brega dove stiamo andando non lo so apri
apri qualcosa chiudi veloce ok bene bene
bene
no guarda nell'armadietto
nell'armadietto pesantissimo già fatto
apposta
questo ha fatto ragazzini case sfondo
aperto la porta posso sentire il tuo
odore non è vero io profumo di chanel
ok tutto l'alto aperto un altro che cura
di mano non aperto il mio aperto il mio
caso ma che palle però è [ __ ] sei
e mezzo di mia suocera la ciccia ragazze
non c'è verso mi trova ovunque dove
dovete van dove devo andare
vedi un cazzo regala non vedo un cazzo
chiude chiudi luglio dio mio dio dove
stiamo andando li precede chiuso merda e
vabbè [ __ ] qui sotto minatori
stato ok calmi calmi anni ok ci siamo a
dei ragazzi io direi che posso
concludere qui per questo episodio
perché è successo di tutto praticamente
niente raga io continuerò nel prossimo
devi sapere ragazzi con un commento se
vi è piaciuto al video comunque se vi è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche a pagani facebook e come noi video
tratte nella descrizione serie se dei
siti scriveteli ci vediamo al prossimo
video e da ragazzi
[Musica]
va bene va bene solo
chopin
[Musica]
qualcuno di voi ragazzi mi spiegherebbe
che cazzo sta facendo